un
programme qui tienne ford
alors que le ramadan et gostivar mr
oui
c'est vrai que c'est déroutant 1 c'est
fou ça le calme est impressionnant avec
le cab alors il ya une autre image aussi
qu'on vous montre et le courage des
citoyens craignant leur motivation c'est
cet homme qui déplace à mains nues une
mine je sais pas si vous avez vu ça à
regarder
un trait ligne f
c'est fou ça c'est fou oui en fait elle
était sur la route je voyais cette mine
est donc ils appellent devait faire du
et justement faire sauter la route et
donc ils se sont arrêtés lula s'est
ployé à chaque fois ça une forte charge
symbolique nous sommes seuls face à la
mine dévastatrice le groupe d'hommes
devant un tank c'est on ne reculera
devant rien le peuple ukrainien se
battra contre l'armée russe s'il le faut
donc c'est très émouvant et tiennent
pour l'instant parce que oui mais on dit
qu'en termes d'image justement pour
l'instant l'ukraine maîtrise très bien
les réseaux sociaux ces images là on va
avoir des infos justement puisque il ya
notre ami qui venait dans un instant
sergei juste après se magner tout donc
ancien espion du kgb à court d'essence
qu'à ses gars et de nombreux véhicules
rue sont abandonnés et certains sont
alors volé par les habitants c'est le
cas ici avec un tracteur 10 permet de
partir avec un véhicule blindé sous les
yeux des soldats regarder
[Musique]
alors ça c'est vrai que celui-là
s'organiser sur serguei quand ça va ça
va très bien fatigués mais ça va c'était
en cours de sf justement école de foot
concert
géant rassemblant klich depuis les faux
alors on voit toutes les images de ce
week-end tiré que c'est incroyable et
une image qui a beaucoup choqué c'est
celle d'un char russe qui dévisse sa
trajectoire au dernier moment un roulé
sur la voiture et un homme c'était au
nord de kiev l'homme a miraculeusement
survécu regarder ça
[Musique]
bon il a échoué quand commence alors il
a survécu c'est incroyable est-ce que je
montrais l'a fait exprès parce que c'est
la puissance parce qu'il ya un char
moyer voilà et c'est la guerre et tout
est permis à quoi et vraiment il sait
mais c'est fou franchement mal cette
image à l'aiea les incroyables séchoir
parce que ces réformes était là avec le
son s'il vous plaît merci avec le son le
début
[Musique]
oui maintenant malgré son bon ça y est
c'est parce qu'en fait c'est lors d'une
bagarre de communication des très
importants évidemment c'est horrible
mais les russes laissent entendre qu'il
a perdu totalement le contrôle de son
chat et les ukrainiens passe les images
en boucle pour montrer qu'ils eurent
foncer dessus
policière ma volonté du sciemment pardon
et du coup c'est effectivement horrible
c'est quoi la vérité la vérité on ne
saura jamais orange par exemple
actuellement il ya le couvre-feu à kiev
et s'est dit à partir de vendredi soir
jusqu'à demain matin
j'ai perdu le fil complètement où on est
on est quinze jours mais non non ça
c'était ce matin c'était jusqu'à ce
matin
il m'a donné le truc donc
cédé jusqu'à est en fait le truc c'est
quand même ils ont
et
le gars
[Rires]
est bon à savoir quand est-ce que ça
s'est passé parce qu'ils ont dit que si
jamais ils voient quelqu'un dans la rue
à partir de 17 heures vendredi jusqu'à 7
heures du matin lundi toute personne est
considérée comme l'ennemi qui est sur
les rails d'accord pourquoi la
communication rudy qui il a perdu le
contrôle de son char c'est c'est fou
bah de toute façon il ya la guerre de
communication tout le temps où vous avez
ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont dit que
poutine a limogé le général guère asimov
de la chef d'état d'état major c'est un
fake mais chacun produit l'effet que les
russes font des faits que les ukrainiens
font des fake c'est la guerre parce que
la guerre c'est pas uniquement avec des
bombes c'est aussi l'information donc
actuellement où il y avait tout ce qui
circule donc voilà pour déstabiliser le
tout après on peut faire des fautes
aussi un peu faire des fautes bas les
gens ils disons qu'ils ont ils ont peur
en foot c'est vrai il a fait quoi le
char après justement il n'est pas x or
on sait pas mais le truc avec avec les
images comme ça le problème c'est que on
connaît pas le lin ou le contexte bien
sûr on n'est pas quand est-ce que ça a
été fait le film est par exemple vous
souvenez il y avait des trucs qui était
présenté comme ici comme il y avait des
djihadistes et qui ont assassiné toute
une école ou d'un verre sans fed et les
taux comme ça et puis après on a on a
appris que ça a été tourné aux états
unis que c'était un film est en fait ils
ont juste utiliser les images pour nous
montrer que c'était pendant la guerre et
c'est donc les images sans contexte
c'est très difficile de rendre on a
d'autres images à ce week-end est
aujourd'hui la ville de kharkiv est sous
les bombardements et des civils sont
malheureusement toucher regarder les
images sont impressionnantes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui ça rejaillit il disait c'est presque
à côté de moi c'est ça parce qu'en fait
putty me disais nous ne bombarde que les
militaires les cibles militaires mais
cela c'est l'asie l'année et vous
souvenez pendant la guerre de
tchétchénie grozny la capitale il a rasé
la ville il a rasé la ville
ils savaient que les gens habités et il
a dit on s'en fout on s'en fout brasse
n'a comme en match c'est une question
parce qu'on disait justement qu'il
n'irait pas faire un tapis de bombes
comme ça parce que il ya des monuments
historiques écueil comics il
s'en fout
mais il s'en fout et des maniements de
rien mais ça continue il a fait ça aussi
en libye en syrie en série de la même
chose ça de bon c'est vrai que les
djihadistes utilise parfois les civils
enfin il se planque en ville et à ce
moment là on ne bombardent pas on fait
grade c'est les katusha vous savez c'est
le tout teinté
on fait ça c'est pas ciblé c'est un
territoire qui est qui qui est anéanti
c'est comme une petite bombe atomique on
va passer au sujet d'après nature merci
[Rires]
je connais quelques jours on est lundi
est bon il connaît le jour des images
les plus impressionnantes ce week-end
c'est aussi celle et on c'est vrai que
c'est fou ce qui se passe quand on voit
des images c'est vrai qu'on voulait
montrer toutes les tâches qu'on passe
notre temps à regarder toutes les images
de ce week end est ce assez c'est celle
d'une explosion incroyable qui a touché
un stock de munitions de munitions
touché par un missile regardez
aujourd'hui moins deux morts
bonjour et
aider à un mot très très gros en russe
ah ouais ouais s'est il étonné mais
quand j'ai vu ça en moi aussi à un
moment donné je me suis dit ça y est il
à l appuyer sur le bouton parce qu'enfin
en fait il y avait un autre endroit dans
lequel d'abord on voit le peu le premier
le premier touché est ce qu'on ne savait
pas c'est que c'est un
un dépôt de carburant d'accord d'abord
il ya eu a été touché et puis après il
ya tout le carburant qui étaient autour
qui passait à sauter c'est donc du
coussac ces dames bout et je me suis dit
ça y est c'est ainsi nucléaire quoi
c'est fou alors dans sept à huit tirs on
a vu que les civils s'engager eux mêmes
à défendre leur pays et leur ville le
gouvernement a décidé de distribuer des
armes à tous les citoyens qui voulaient
se défendre regarde de simples citoyens
qui arrive les mains vides devant le
commissariat central de kiev et
repartent avec un fusil d'assaut un
gilet pare-balles et des munitions ces
gens là pourraient se retrouver dans
quelques heures face aux chars de
vladimir poutine en quelques jours la
ville de kiev a distribué 18 mille armes
mort aux ennemis
aujourd'hui ce sont 110 ou sergei
la résistance ukrainienne est plus
importante que ce que pensaient les
l'éruption absolument cesser c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que poutine il ne
s'attendait absolument pas je crois que
il croyait que le cren est resté en 2014
en dessert 14 du temps de crime et du
temps de début parce qu'il faut bien le
rappeler rappelons tout le temps la
guerre n'a pas commencé il ya cinq jours
la guerre a commencé il ya huit ans et
ça fait huit ans qu'il fait la guerre
qui fait la guerre et le crête est donc
en fait et croyez que les ukrainiens à
neymar et qu' il allait accueillir les
russes même active c'est une ville qui a
priori est à la frontière nord
à la frontière avec la russie et donc on
parle beaucoup aux russes beaucoup plus
que l'ukrainien attractif et en fait
poutine raconte que les russophones en
ukraine il adore la russie est en fait
la preuve c'est que s'il adore la russie
pourquoi les bombarde avec les grades
c'est avec les cas touchant c'est que en
fait il ya contre n'importe quoi oui
j'aurais dit oui à dire quelque chose
non non effectivement la résistance et
puis je pense qu'aussi poutine est
surpris par la solidarité aussi de tout
le monde entier contre haas ça c'est
encore encore plus important encore est
important s'il s'attendait absolument
pas absolument pas que le monde entier
vous aimez vous visiez suède suède un
pays pacifiste il fournit les armes la
suisse la suède 6 avec la société là sur
la suisse a cessé rallier ses horaires
aux sanctions fait donc les suisses avec
leur banquier ils vont dire ils ont dit
nous ce rallye l'allemagne qui n'avait
jamais fourni d'armes létales depuis 45
c'est ça des fils l'a d'ailleurs quand
il ya eu les premières mêlées brison il
y avait les pays baltes qui est qu'ils
ont dit on va livrer les armes qui
appartenait à l'allemagne auront 1 à
stoke on a pour l'instant on les utilise
pas on allait fournir l'ukraine
l'allemagne a à donner son veto et l'a
dit non je n'en faut pas les donner
maintenant ils ont changé d'avis et non
seulement bien changer d'avis ils ont
dit on va renforcer nos pompes d'essence
on a dépensé 100
200 milliards d'euros pour la défense
d'allemagne braquer ou la chine est ce
qu'au vu de sa personnalité vous pensez
que d'avoir le monde entier contre lui
comme ça va plus il va puisse se dire je
vais me calmer on va tout arrêter ou
est-ce que ça va encore plus l'énervé et
se dire je vais te défoncer et sam est
encore pire je voudrais vous rassurer
mais c'est plutôt le deuxième le
deuxième chose ouais parce que quand il
était à l'école à l'école du kgb en fait
on a un ami dans son dossier c'est une
personne qui n'arrive pas à mesurer le
danger est donc il est dangereux pour
lui même mais aussi pour le service et
c'est pour ça le service ne l'a n'a pas
voulu de lui la renvoyer aline grotte
mais donc le kgb qu'on a tout compris on
oser pas les questions dans le sujet
contraste à l'heure vous l'accordé
conducteur donc c'est comme si c'était
par rapport aux russes eux-mêmes est ce
que il n'y aurait pas une fissure dans
l'édifice
poutine sur son sol même parce que on
voit quand même il ya déjà un oligarque
là qui s'est retournée contre saison
oui mais si si si si si la russie ne le
suis pas au rassemblement il ya eu déjà
un député qui a dit j'ai voté le truc de
la république parce que je croyais que
c'était la paix mais quand j'ai vu la
guerre je retire ma signature donc en
fait il serait payant mathieu darmon la
question si je peux aider du coup sûr le
sur le foot ma question c'est si on
énerve tout le monde et si si on ne fait
rien et tout le monde la conclusion
c'est qu'on peut pas grand chose mais ça
peut c'est un petit peu compliqué est-ce
que nous il ya moyen de le tuer lui ou
c'est totalement impossible comme cet
été pour 7 des mulsanne et pour d'autres
non je crois qu'il ya moyen mais il ya
moyen peut-être vous savez j'ai fait un
truc un peu fou sur sur ma chaîne
youtube j'ai dit pendant le premier jour
les oligarques russes ont fallait les
très très riches ils ont perdu 40
milliards d'euros ou de dollars peu
importe de capitalisation de
l'entreprise d'abord ils ont perdu 40
milliards mais je leur dis vous mettez
une petite annonce dans le journal celui
que me rapporte poutine lui au mort ou
vif un milliard d'euros il sera morte
dans deux jours non
non mais un milliard
imagine son garde de corps son garde du
corps c'est vrai et on dit on va te
donner un milliard le gars il va dire
oui je sauve la planète et l'une d'un
côté il et puis là il est là une
protection et non et il a une protection
énorme mais de toute façon les gars
conduit ça dépend de tous les gens qui
sont autour de lui parce que ici il sait
plus car tout seul on ne sert pour
manger on ne sert pour changer pour se
changer en effet son lit on l'accompagné
en confiance une belle confiance à
personne donc si c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que
doit avoir confiance parce que l'on peut
très bien l'empoisonner brinon il est
obligé il est obligé parce que qu'est-ce
qui va faire de toute façon il était
tout seul quand on arrive à ce point de
pouvoir on est on est toujours tout seul
à ne les gars pareil tu as une facture
10 milliards tu dis on va me prendre en
otage me torturer pour m'extorquer les
démineurs donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
mais ça si je dis à une personne normale
dans la vie ils disent ouais c'est
n'importe quoi anoh les gars c'est une
belle vie belle nana les villas etc mais
non ils dorment pas ils dorment pas moi
j'ai ski j'ai parmi mes connaissances
mais qu'on essaye âgées deux oligarques
russes rencontre avec kirk les gars et
c'est un homme très très riche au delà
de la famille armada milliards d'accord
on l'ya au delà d'un milliard soit un
oligarque
j'ai jamais deux delà des murs potanine
et boris titov avec lesquels j'ai fait
mes études à rome du maupas lumière cité
et on a c'est ça c'est ça ernest
guillier ensemble à courchevel un ça va
et après tout est ce qui l a tous s'unir
et en fait je le voyais dans leurs yeux
qu'ils m'en veuillent ou non ah ouais
bah moi celle que vous aviez même pull
[Rires]
c'est l'humain mais c'est là pour vous
en vrai pourquoi ils sont jamais
tranquille parce qu'ils sont jamais
temps et je vais vous dire mais c'est
vrai que c'est normal c'est vrai c'est
vrai que je comprends oui si on toujours
en train de absolument absolument
regarder déjà tiré est-ce qu'il peut
sortir dans la dans la rude à paris non
non c'est grave ou vous êtes d'accord
mais cyril six ans il ya il ya une note
de 1000 personnes autour de lui dix
mille jimmy la question sur des
faisceaux
pour un million d'euros son garde du
corps diego nous livre pour un mignon
non
millions peut-être peut-être n'ont-ils
et pont déjà par mois
[Rires]
déchirée on rigole mais c'est vrai que
les images qu'on voit sont ils sont très
très dur on va regarder dans leur permet
dé la nuit
deux filles semaine que vous avez vu
genton
il a changé physiquement
il est complètement changé vous savez
pas ce que c'est on en reparle et
ordonné il ya quand même une donnée moi
qui trouve que je trouve important est
ce que vladimir poutine et est vraiment
malade comme on le dit ou pas ça c'est
vraiment la question a je crois je ne
veux pas dire qu'il est malade parce que
si les malades les malades vraiment
aussi pas mal à dos est là c'est parce
qu'on croit qu'ils ont du mal à z comme
ça on dit qu'il aurait pu prendre un
livre 11 idrissa
en fait si c'est juste un 15 heures
c'est pas grave parce que mitterrand
avait un cancer pendant 14 ans mais
hélas il a eu de mandat comme président
avec un concert parce qu'on lui a
annoncé le concert une semaine après son
arrivée au pouvoir dick autres sur les
images c'est que les gaver de cortisone
c'est qu'il arrive être mais ça va un
signe d'une maladie
le dioxyde trois ans ça joue quand même
sur ses décisions absolument voilà
absolument surtout que si ce sont
condamnés bien sûr fait issues d'imagés
mais il a quand même de ceux de deux
filles il a quand même fruit mais bon si
je pose la question bien sûr est simple
ce rapport à l'alcool ce qui paraît qu
est-ce qu est-ce qu il est l colis
qu'est-ce qui lé nom est non
s'il ya une chose qu'on ne peut pas lui
reprocher on peut dire n'importe quoi
sur lui bois quasiment pas thomas jammes
un
sk vous dit votre source kremlin depuis
trois ans sur sa maladie c'est que il
est malade il va mourir d'ici mais c'est
ça aussi pourquoi je crois pas parce que
il a commencé à lui dire ils vont mourir
va mourir dans deux trois semaines dans
un mois et c'est ça fait déjà trois ans
qu'il est là qu environ quand ils ont
commencé à le dire donc du coup on se
méfie quand même pis les soigner quand
même bien y aller les médecins
m'ont d'israël qui est soigné les
médecins russes et puis avec son
ministre de la défense tient chaud et
vous sert kiki choïgou s'est illuminé
zone de la défense les deux qui est
qu'on a vu hier
choïgou fagots il s'appelle sociale ou
sergueï choïgou ta gueule
parce qu'ils annoncent les sites
facebook et skype est en fait il vient
de tout va c'est une petite république
en sibérie de teva tout va aux ti va on
va en fait tout va en russe et la diva
des bâches ayant chaise ou est ce qui va
et donc c'est comme les amérindiens aux
états unis et tous les trois mois il les
mène en sibérie voir les chamans et qui
les chamans et aujourd'hui à mal des
danses adacore presque satanique